[موسيقى]
انا اريد ان اعيد
البلده القديمه في القدس ليه لان تكون
بلده عربيه واضحه المعالم على عكس ما
بينتقل له الاسرائيليين في تحويل الايماج
المظهر العام بمدينه القدس لان يكون اكثر
يهوديه من حقيقته العربيه الواضحه اللي هي
الحقيقه العربيه لا منزلنا وتصميمنا
وبنائنا
انا شخصيا لا اسمعيها موهبه انا اسميها
هوايه
الهوايه بدات من الطفوله من الطفوله هوايه
الحفر على الخشاب لما اشوفك كنت اشوف خالي
لما شفت
الفنيين في المسجد الاقصى فين كنا نعيش
كنا نسكن في الطفوله والفنين
سلموني شويه اشتغل معهم يعني تقريبا
[موسيقى]
تغديت اشتغل بالصوره يدويه بالاول الى انت
شفت انه ممكن الواحد يصمم قبل الكمبيوتر
وينفذ عبر اله السي ان سي او
الليزر ومن ثم يعود الى العمل اليدوي في
تلوين الزجاج في تنظيف وفي دهانه في
اختيار الالوان كله هذا البيت من ذوق
شخصيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اني اعمل لوحات في بيوت المقدسيين وبيوت
العرب اينما كانوا
للمحافظه على هذا الفن من الضياع الفنان
ما بدنا اياه يكون بس في المساجد والكنائس
بدنا اياه في بيوتنا
في بيوتنا في شبابيك عندنا بيوتنا
تصاميمها اليوم تصاميم شاذه
منقوله بدون تنسيق وبدون شيء احنا بحاجه
الى ان نطفي الروح العربيه على واجهات
منازلنا على الاقل على شبابيك بعض شبابيك
في منازلها للنعطي انه هذا شباك بيت عربي
فعلا
[موسيقى]